I had an incredible curiosity toward the
Israeli society even though I grew up in
a very liberal left-wing pro-palestinian
family in Beirut we grew up in a very
very hostile environment where we were
raised me yeah I'm not gonna speak big
politics I'm gonna say just my own
personal life we were raised with this
incredible hatred for this enemy and we
were raised all our life not believing
that the Israeli or the Jews have a
perspective or or have a narrative I
mean when you're a teenage you're
growing up and you hear about the Yom
Kippur War and all these wars you cannot
expect from a child and a teenage to
grow up thinking like let me listen to
the other side it's too much to ask for
so it's impossible right when I went to
Los Angeles and I attended film school
in San Diego State it is a very very
slow progression where you sit down with
supposedly the enemy you meet Israeli
students you meet Jewish students and
then you kind of have there's always a
tension because this is how my
background is but then you know you
start taking back and forth there is a
dialogue that goes back and forth and
you light a cigarette with them then
that's it suddenly I'm sitting with
somebody who has my own insecurities too
who has his own dialogue too this is
what's so important and it was a very
very slow process if you've asked me to
do the attack 25 years ago I would not
have been able to do it it had to take a
lot of time and when I stumbled upon
that material and we started adapting
the screenplay
I felt so in relationship with that
character who was ambivalent and who
whenever you want to rise above the
conflict
you're probably condemned to lose that
battle and this is how we took that
script and we started doing it we went
and financed that movie Qatar the
country of Qatar had came up with a film
fund wanting to promote film from the
Middle East so we apply the film and
they give us some money and we went and
shot the film they gave us a big part of
the money canal priest from France gave
us a little bit the Belgium government
gave us a little bit but the main money
came from Qatar and an Egyptian producer
very famous Egyptian producer that was
like one of the few times where money
was being invested in independent Arab
cinema and we went to Telluride last
year and then after Taylor I went to
Toronto so the Qataris were very happy
and they flew to Toronto to attend the
screening because they haven't seen it
yet and after the screening was over
they were doing a cocktail and they
invited us and I came with my producer
Sean Rhea and then the the head of him
took us to the side and he says look we
gotta tell you something we need you to
take our name off the screen credit I
said why he says how much it cost I said
I want you to they paid the money it's
not they're gonna recover the money they
just did not want their name on the on
the film I said you gotta give me a
reason why I should take it I'll take it
off you know that's why but he says
because that prop that film cause us
some problem I said what are the
problems he says look we are showing
both perspective and we understand but
we are Qatar is going at a time right
now last year where we're involved in
some revolutions in the Arab world he
says because that movie could open some
doors we don't want to face right now I
said but you an Arab country you came up
with the idea that you want to promote
democracy arab arab films this is your
idea not mine he says look you're
looking at the tree we're looking at the
forest my producer told me later he
actually overcharged them to take the
credit of the family why not and then
and then the film went to the egyptian
producer who saw it and then she said i
can't have my name on the film i said
why she says why do you show a
Palestinian committing an act blowing
kids in the restaurant and you're not
showing what the Israeli do there to the
Palestinian I said because this is not
the story the story is not about Israeli
what they do the film is about a story
of a woman a modern Christian liberal
supposedly pretty woman who blows it
herself up in a restaurant this is the
story not the other way he says yeah but
you could have used some shots showing
the jeannine massacre I says the Janine
is symbolic the Janine is just we wanted
to show the rub the rubble we want to
show the destruction and I did not want
to see veiled women and kids going out
and crying because it's not in the story
and that she says that causes us problem
I said Hadid what is the problem she
says I can't have you release that film
it took six months of negotiation and a
couple of months ago where finally they
agreed to release the film the 1955 law
forbid me to go to Israel
I wanna did it when the authorities saw
the movie they gave us the approval
about it but then there is a committee
in Lebanon it's called the Israel
boycott committee but five six people
who probably drink the shisha from time
to time and and they made this campaign
about stopping the movie they contacted
the Arab League and the Arab League
asked the Lebanese government and all
the Arab countries to ban the movie
there are massacres going on in Syria
rape crime big time the Arab League
cannot find a unified voice to condemn
it yet they managed to find a unified
voice to ban the movie so and I said it
in the BBC Press I said Ziad we're
unified the Arabs for the first time
sometimes the simplest thing could solve
big things because we tried the big
things in my life none of them worked
not a single time and I find out that
the Lebanese and Israeli in a lot of
ways are so similar
they are both similar in term of climate
in term of the color of the asphalt in
term of the shrubbery in the street and
I left and I came back and I said it
would have been really nice to be able
one day it sounds naive but this is how
I function to be one day to say I'm
going for weekend to have an express
when Tel Aviv and be back it's only 200
kilometers from Beirut to Tel Aviv yet
it seemed so far away